hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game that happened yesterday
it is from the St Louis Rapids
tournament so it's a rapid game uh of
course I forgot to change the letter on
the little robot so just give me a
second uh there we go and uh just as we
are recovering from that Masterpiece
that stava played yesterday we are
treated to another one here ala fu is
facing Wesley so and unlike yesterday's
Masterpiece this one is left unfinished
so you guys will have a chance in a
pause the video moment to finish the
Masterpiece so let's check it out alza
has the white pieces and interestingly
we follow the exact same game I already
covered uh yesterday or the day before
yesterday where shich played against
rajabu where he defeated him in that
line that was already played by many
others including Wesley so himself with
the white pieces so this is a uh a lot
of Mind trickery in this one so okay
let's uh go after it E4 E5 Knight F3
Knight to F6 going for the Petro defense
and now Knight captures an E5 like I
said if you watch the shich versus arabo
video then it's the exact same thing
Knight F3 Knight captures on e4 D4 D5
and now Bishop to D3 uh Bishop to F5 we
have
castles uh Bishop to E7 Rook to E1 and
Castle so everything the same nothing
new here Knight beat to D2 and now
Knight to D6 offering a trade of light
Square Bishops but Knight to F1 of
course you would like the the trade to
happen on D3 so Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Pawn to C6 we have
Bishop to F4 Knight to A6 and now Pawn
to H4 everything the same Knight to C7
Pawn to G6 uh and now uh sorry uh first
Knight to G5 threatening Checkmate and
now Pawn to G6 and we reach the position
that happened in
thear charab of game where asage played
Knight to G3 which was a completely new
move so it has never been played before
and the moves that we discussed in that
position were Knight to E3 that was
already played by Fabiano corana also an
burkic played it and Knight to H2 uh
which sorry Knight A3 that Wesley played
uh but Knight to H2 that Fabiano played
and here we have Knight to H2 uh and now
uh there are a couple of games that
reach this position where F6 was played
and also Queen to D7 is a noral queen to
D7 played by uh also Fabiano had a game
where he played with the white pieces
against mamaro mamaro played Queen to D7
and we have a game that an B played
against Maxim matlakov matlakov played
Ponto F6 and in both of those games uh
the player with the white pieces
celebrated Victory but here we have
Knight to F5 and it is now already as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game so uh the the action will happen uh
immediately Knight to G4 and now Bishop
to D6 offering a trade of light Square
Bishops dark Square Bishops and much
like in the sh jaabo game You're
Expecting Bishop captures and D6 Queen
captures and D but no uh here ala uh was
of an unrestful spirit so to say and he
played b a queen captures on F5 I mean
this is just this is just amazing to to
see such a move uh point is that the
Knight will uh connect with the king and
the bishop on D6 and he will get some
material in return so let's see what
happens you cannot capture the bishop
first because then Queen captures on F4
so G captures on F5 accepting the queen
and now Knight the H6 with check uh if
you go here then uh the queen will be
recaptured right away so that's not
really great you have to go forward King
to G7 and now Knight captures on F5 with
check nicely connects with the bishop on
D6 the King goes to G6 and now Knight
captures on D6 okay you want some
material for the queen but not a lot uh
Pawn to H5 stopping white from uh
playing Pawn to H5 because then you
might have to worry about something like
Rook to E3 then The Rook um can get
control of the H file and here alza has
to choose does he want to go for The
Rook lift or does he want to play Knight
captur some B7 grab more material harass
the queen and maybe figure out what to
do from there uh Rook to E3 is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
but it yields only a draw for example
Rook E3 F6 challenges the Knight Rook to
G3 and after captures captures uh
there's not much to be done here you can
even go under the mask of the bishop
because the Rook is also attacking the
bishop so Rook F5 a discovery you're
just going to repeat there's nothing
better here so alza wants to continue he
plays Knight captures on B7 attacks the
black queen here and queen to C8
attacking the Knight Knight to C5 and
now we have Rook to E8 now uh Wesley
says all right you didn't want to go for
The Rook lift you're not going for it
now but alza says yes I am he plays Rook
captures on E8 and you cannot capture
with the queen and control the E file as
the Knight on C7 would hang so Knight
captures on E8 and now Rook to E1 ala
manages to bring another attacker into
the game and now he has a knight Bishop
Pawn Rook soon to join the action and
the other Knight on C5 sort of
surrounding the black king can he finish
this game we have Queen to F5 going
after the bishop and now Knight to D3
defending the bishop and also the C2
pawn pawn to F6 and now alza doesn't
play Knight to E6 or something that you
might expect or maybe a going back with
the Knight but instead goes Rook to E7
he tries to sacrifice the Knight as well
but if you capture the Knight then comes
Knight to E5 check the E5 square has
been cleared for the Knight King F6 if
you go King F6 of course just Bishop
captures and G5 and now you have to give
up the queen there are no squares for
the black king and if you go King to H6
then H captures and G5 again all of the
squares here are covered you have to
give up the queen for the pawn and
Bishop so that's not going to work after
Rook D7 Wiley says all right I cannot
capture the Knight Knight to G7 and now
Rook to F7 putting pressure on on that
F6 pawn and now uh what can what can
Wesley do he of course brings The Rook
into the game now comes Bishop to E5 if
the Knight cannot be captured then the
bishop cannot be captured either and now
Knight to E8 you could also just play
Queen captures on G5 and say okay I'm
going to take the Knight take the Rook
on F7 we trade down and we play an end
game H but Wesley still wants the fight
he plays Knight the8 and defends the F6
Pawn F3 by Ala it looks like a slow move
but the PA will come in very handy um
when it's time to advance that g Pawn
Plus also Wesley is sort of in a two
swung there really uh isn't a useful
move he can do in this position and a
move like A6 or A5 is probably the best
thing to do uh just letting alza play
something because black does not have a
move here you can play something like
King to H6 maybe hoping to repeat a
position but Wesley played Queen to C8
and now he allows alza to actually win
the game and Ala plays it right away
Knight to F4 with check King to F5 and
now it's time to find the winning idea
it's not an easy one so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for ala
while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
finishing this brilliancy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is not Knight captures on H5 which Al
is a play it's actually Knight to H7 I'm
going to show why uh the reason is that
well Knight to H7 you are if black plays
a move let's say A6 you will play Knight
captures on F6 and checkm the black king
that's the that's the idea so uh the
only thing Wesley will be able to do is
to add a Defender to F6 but it doesn't
help now you're just going to uh trade
down into a winning end game Bishop
captures on F6 Knight captures and now
Rook captures forcing The Black Queen to
capture captures captures and captures
Knight Will capture on H5 with check and
once the king moves you are up um you
are up four pawns uh so four pawns uh
for the exchange is more than enough for
you to win win the game and of those
four three are already pass Pawn so it's
it will be fairly easy to win this
however ala tried something else he
played Knight captures on H5 first and
it's actually uh in regard to what he
already played F3 preparing Checkmate
again if you play something like A6 then
Checkmate will very quickly happen King
to G6 Knight to F4 with check now and
after the king moves to H6 Rook to H7
will be Checkmate so this is what alza
wants but Wesley says nope not going to
happen Rook captures on G5 he gives back
some material now Knight captures on F6
again hoping for Knight captures and
Rook captures with Checkmate as the
bishop and pawn are covering all of the
squares here uh but Wesley just hides
the king king to G6 we have Rook to f8
uh attacking the Knight here and Rook to
F5 and amazingly the the position is
still winning but you have to throw in
one move that it's not easy to spot in
Rapid alza went for Rook captures on E8
right away but the move to spot is I
know you guys don't even have to pause
the video for this one uh Pawn to H5
with check and the reason is you have to
capture it because if the king moves
then you just Checkmate the black king
king to for example here and Bishop to
G3 will be Checkmate all the other lines
and in Checkmate as well so you will
have to capture it and now that the Rook
moves now you will play Rook captures on
E8 and after the queen moves now you
will capture the Knight as well and
after Queen captures now for example
Rook E6 check you win the C7 uh C6 Pawn
as well and you are up four pawns um a
queen a bishop and rook and four pawns
for a queen that will be winning unless
maybe black miraculously finds some sort
of a Perpetual but objectively it will
be winning but after Rook F5 uh rapid
format is too too much to to spot such
intricacies ala played Rook captures on
E8 right away and now just Queen to B7
uh H5 with check but now you can go to
F7 that's the difference once The Rook
moved from f8 King to F7 became a
possibility Rook to B8 and now Queen to
E7 uh just threatening to to give back
any material in order to to survive this
attack uh but still Wesley will have to
fight hard H6 now H7 and h8 both squares
are covered so if the queen comes into
the game it's all over Rook captures on
E5 and now the a moment where it almost
seems like you can play H7 and win the
game you cannot if you play H7 then Rook
the E1 with check and if King to H2 then
even Queen captures on F6 you can allow
white to promote his Pawn to a queen but
now Queen F4 check and you will very
very quickly checkmated the white king
queen to F5 with check King has to go up
the board or you advance the pawn now
Queen captures King H4 check Rook H2
check King to G5 and now you don't even
have to capture the White Queen you can
deliver a check M here King to F5 and
Rook to F2 will be Checkmate so that's
the problem so after Rook captures on E5
D captures on E5 was played and now
Queen captures on E5 we have Rook to f8
with check one last attempt by alza at
winning the game because if King
captures the Knight to D7 with a
beautiful Royal Fork uh but after Rook
to f8 check King to G6 was played and
now ala has nothing better than to Advan
the pawn and allowed this nasty
Perpetual check so H7 was played
threatening h8 Queen but now uh Wesley
just goes Queen to E1 check King H2 and
it's now a Perpetual there's nothing
more to try here King H2 Queen to H4
check King to G1 and queen to E1 with
check and he was in this position on
move 44 the players agreed to a draw or
rather it is now a forc draw by
three-fold repetition so uh incredible
game and it's uh amazing to me that we
see a repetition of this line
either either ala was following what
happened in the game between shich and
rajabov or he watched my video and that
inspired him to go for this either way
uh he he took it to the next level he
found this very nice uh Queen sacrifice
I imagine over the board because the
position has never been seen before and
it was possible to uh to to finish the
Masterpiece but in the crucial moment
here where um Knight to F4 check was
played which leads to a win ala missed
the only winning idea and that is KN to
H7 but even later on it was possible to
win with H5 uh but you know uh such is
the way way of the of the rapid chess uh
so yeah once again big congratulations
to those of you who were able to finish
the Masterpiece you are an excellent
player uh and yeah I would like to thank
iofi toon Chen bohu and siik Nick Donald
Duncan Parker Andreas rosenal and David
gasparian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
of course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out the first
link in the description below if you
haven't seen yesterday's game uh see you
soon